hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in meditation 3
one of the things that Rene Descartes is
considering that plays an integral role
in the argument and the explanations
that he's providing by which he's
gradually reconstructing his account of
reality is the Providence of our ideas
that is where our ideas are coming from
how are they coming to us are they
within us already are we producing them
are they coming from outside things and
that's the tripart distinction that he
is going to make and then more
importantly rely upon this distinction
is sometimes difficult to follow and to
grasp and it's not helped by the
language that many of the translations
use which which actually comes from
decart's latin which which is good to
take a look at in this case we generally
talk about three types of ideas that
decart himself recognizes and those
three one of them is very important
plays a major role later on doesn't play
such an important role in meditation 3
in 8 and then we have what we call
adventitious ideas right in the Malayan
ex his autem
that's of these ideas ah di and not a
that is some are born with us right Ali
I Advent it ci that's coming from
something else and then we have ideas
that we can call produced and when we
say produced we mean produced by us so
let's let's recap these now actually
looking at dick Hurtz
own words he says of the ideas some seem
to be born with me that's what it means
to be innate that means that these are
ideas that we wouldn't necessarily
already be thinking but we already have
them within us in some way and when we
direct what he calls the natural light
to shine upon them when we're using our
attention we can automatically access
them and they may take a little bit of
you know working with to become
completely clear for us but they're
there they're there already we don't
have to produce them by our own work the
operative powers of our mind they're
already within us just waiting to be
called up then we have ideas that you
know we're calling here adventitious
ideas that are arriving in the french
literally from outside right door and
the notion here is that these are the
ideas that would come to us for example
from sensing visible objects we we see
the object and we get the idea of the
object was the card thinks of it's sort
of a image or a representation of it
uses both of those terms and we have the
idea in our mind that and we could say
that about a smell right the smell is a
certain image of the thing that we're
smelling we smell something because it
comes on us from from the outside or you
know it could be that there really is no
outside and these ideas are coming to us
from some evil demon as he suggested
causing us to lose elucidate in that
case it would still be coming from
something
not coming from us and then he says we
have ideas that are made fit in French
and invented or discovered on Vontae by
myself in in de cartes case he's talking
about himself or by ourselves and you
know what would be some examples of this
well he gives us a number of examples he
tells us I have the Faculty of
conceiving what we in general can call a
thing or a truth or a thought and it
seems that I don't get this from
anything other than my own specific or
proper nature these are ideas that are
so general that I already have them
within my mind I didn't form them by
looking at things in the world but
they're already there for me I use them
to make sense of the things in the world
so to speak when it comes to
adventitious ideas then he says you know
if I hear something a certain sound or
if I see the Sun or if I sense heat up
until this this hour
I've actually judged that these
sentiments are feelings preceded or
arrived from some things that exist
outside of myself and then we can think
of the work of the imagination that
would be a prime example of ideas that I
have created through my own operative
powers so he says you know we can think
of sirens hippogriffs and all the other
similar cámaras which are fictions and
inventions of my own mind so he says
also perhaps I can persuade myself that
all of these ideas would be of that
genre that we call adventitious or
external coming from outside
why because maybe they're they're not
born with me or that they're born with
me or that they were all created by me
because I don't any at this point in
time have a clear idea of their origin
maybe the idea of a unicorn was innate
or maybe I've seen a unicorn somewhere
now
Descartes then says all right what could
be a criterion for telling these things
apart maybe one criterion could be
whether it's up to me whether I can
choose or not choose to produce these
ideas wouldn't that be a great way to
separate them so he says you know with
with some of these reasons you know that
it seems that they're taught to be by
nature and then there's others that I
experience in myself that don't depend
at all on my will often these present
themselves to me despite what I do or
against what I do for you know example
whether I'm you know if I'm awake or
whether I'm not awake I feel heat and
for this cause I am persuaded that the
feeling or rather that idea of heat is
produced in me by something different
than myself or you know we can talk
about all sorts of other things you know
maybe I hear sounds or I smell odors or
I have a taste or I have a feeling and
it's not up to me whether I feel that or
not so he goes on and he says well we've
got to be careful in these distinctions
first off the things that seem to be
innate definitely the things that we see
by the natural light those are innate
and I've discovered some of them already
in the meditations you know for example
that if I doubt I must exist that's
that's something that we can actually
say as a truth is already there within
me right
to be found but I've got these other
things that I call my nature and their
inclinations and sometimes they lead me
astray sometimes they actually don't
take me in the right direction and so
perhaps those are actually produced by
me and then he goes on and considers
something else that's that's quite
interesting he says for the other reason
that these ideas must come from outside
because they don't depend on my volition
or will I actually don't find that
convincing why because just like the
inclinations that I was just talking
about are found in me even though they
don't accord always with my volition or
choice also or similarly perhaps theirs
in me some sort of faculty or power
which is prone to produce these ideas
without the aid or help of any exterior
things even though it doesn't seem to be
known to me so what is he talking about
there he doesn't go into any further
detail we might think about that as
something like the unconscious or you
know our Faculty of putting things
together and in perception against our
own choice when we exercise our
imagination it's not always bringing
things up that we are ourselves choosing
to imagine sometimes our imagination
runs away with us doesn't it but it
would still be ideas that I'm producing
myself they're still coming from me
maybe if it's you know things like
affective states like feelings
associated with a certain thought once I
have that thought the fear or anger or
joy or whatever it is
arises within me well in that case I'm
responsible for producing that now
what's the upshot of this distinction he
you
this continually throughout meditation
three and it's a good one to keep in
mind through the rest of it and he asks
himself where do my ideas of certain
things come from many of them it turns
out he thinks could not be adventitious
but could be produced maybe there is no
external world and maybe I'm the one
who's actually producing most of these
ideas whether I realize it or not so he
talks about a number of different ideas
of things that we have at our disposal
at this point what is the idea of myself
and he says that one you know I've
already got I've already thought about
myself it includes understanding and
willing and denying and affirming and
loving and hating and it goes on and on
with all the different modes of thought
but there's something else that's
important in this as well in
understanding his idea of himself he has
grasped himself as a substance as a
thing that thinks right he's also
grasped himself in terms of duration and
in terms of number and this is going to
be quite important when it comes to
thinking about other corporeal things
that are non animate he says that I
could have gotten my idea of these other
corporeal things I could be producing
themselves by taking these these basic
components of the idea of myself and
then just you know changing them around
in different ways whether I realize I'm
doing it whether I'm consciously doing
it or whether I'm just sort of happening
you know to do this in the background
and then I discover these ideas of books
and the world and air and all these
other sorts of things so maybe the idea
of corporeal things is really something
instead of being adventitious instead of
coming from outside things that those
ideas would be representations of maybe
I've produced those what about other
things like people or
animals or angels Descartes says I could
have produced those ideas notice that he
doesn't say I could have produced them
by thinking about myself and then
projecting another self out there he
says I could have produced those by
taking the idea of God and corporeal
things and combining them in some way so
as to get beings that would be animate
that would have agency that would have
certain perfections I so to speak place
them in between God at the one extreme
and inanimate corporeal things at the
other and put them like right here in
the middle as existing things that have
a kind of agency sort of like God what
about my idea of God this is going to be
the one idea Descartes says that I
definitely could not have produced so
his you know long story short it's
actually going to turn out to be in an
eighth idea rather than an adventitious
idea although in a certain sense you
could say as an innate idea it is an
adventitious idea because it's so to
speak the stamp that the creator has
placed within a certain kind of creation
right human being but the upshot here is
that the idea of God as opposed to these
other ideas which either I derive for
myself because it is the idea of myself
or I derive for myself by taking ideas
that I've already got at my disposal and
combining them and recombining them and
modifying them in certain ways the idea
of God cannot be something like that for
take heart that's going to be a linchpin
for the argument here and that's part of
why this distinction between different
main classes of ideas based on their
origins is going to be so central in
meditation 3
you